[Musik]
erst dann habe ich ein video auf einem
kanal hochgeladen in dem ich eure hilfe
benötigt habe
denn you know me ich habe mich mal
wieder verliebt ich habe übrigens auch
in den finger geschnitten effekt guter
fokus das ist das schlimmste schmerzen
kann man sich den finger in die haut
schneidet ich habe auch damals als kind
immer so kleine stecknadeln so durch die
haut am finger geschoben fragt mich
nicht ich war schon immer ein bisschen
komisch und christian fitzek
damit ging er zu den bayern aber mache
nicht so mit mir allerdings würde ich
sagen meine lieben freunde starten wir
jetzt mit der tatsache warum wir uns ja
eigentlich versammelt haben
die komme das mädchen wenn das video
hier seht um mein gott du warst das luca
ich dachte es war eine mülltonne
oh mein gott das war es schon das ist
mein freund aber nice dass luca auf mich
steht
das muss ich euch noch erzählen ich
hatte heute morgen eine
fahrkartenkontrolle bahn ich bin sogar
normal u-bahn gefahren hier in hamburg
und dann kam also eine kontrolleurin und
meinte sie ja ihr ticket bitte dann habe
ich es halt gezeigt und sie meinte zu
mir das ist aber ein kinder ticket und
da möchte ich einfach nur da sehen sie
mal wie lange ich hier schon auf die
bahn war zunächst die einfach day die
dahin irgendwann kommt sie safe auch
luca kennt ihr ein mädchen mit einem
bruder ich ja meine schwester ich habe
daraus gelernt das nächste mal wird
meine beschreibung ein bisschen genauer
luca wie viel wie bringe ich die sieht
aus wie die lesebrille von meinem opa da
wenig zu 100 prozent bei dir allerdings
kaufe ich mir diese brille ja auch nicht
ich muss die nur gerade testen anhand
der sehstärke oderland des farbverlauf
aber irgendwie ist generell so dass
produkte vor allem kleidung die teurer
sie wird desto hässlicher wird sie auch
gegen wie zum beispiel bei mir im lukas
eigentlich extrem münster minister von
de luca folgende situation ich habe ein
mädchen gesehen ich bloß nicht schon
wieder hat mein kopf schallt ab mein
ipad akku leer
ja so ist glaube ich bei jedem meiner
zuschauer bei jedem meiner videos luca
macht einfach sein eigenes hilf mir
weil es aber schon mobbing hier ein
bisschen der eigentlichen
lieblingsgemüse habe ich mich gestern
rahmen gefallen weil ich gekocht habe
wenn wir sind luca verliebt sich mia
chicago gehen ja ich verstehe die ganze
kommentare ich verstehe ihren unmut aber
wir müssen wirklich jetzt mal die kirche
im dorf lassen und am besten auch noch
den bahnhof sonst können die im dorf
links wohin fahren
doch das rathaus das lassen wir auch
noch da weil sonst was passiert jetzt
auch nicht so häufig dass ich nicht
verliebt
ja bitte nicht antworten darauf ich bin
drin ich bin drin kann man auch komplett
falsch verstehen ich bin drin
ich bin drin ich bin drin beim ersten
mal für mich war das ganz klar eine
ebene so etwas nichts zu tun also mit
sex hab ich schon was zu tun ich habe
sogar relativ mein gott ich wollte auch
immer wenn ich singe ich dass ich bin
die einzige h
es gibt halt wirklich so viele dinge wo
ich mir mein leben lang gedacht habe
mensch die haben irgendwie nur ich aber
dann habe ich euch kennengelernt und das
ganze leben hat wieder sinn gemacht das
eigentlich nicht aber schon jetzt schon
ganz okay es gibt halt wirklich ganz
ganz viele sachen die mir jetzt einfach
erst aufgefallen sind dass nicht nur ich
das hat es immer noch andere personen so
beispielsweise beim kacken erkennt jetzt
generell beim kacken wenn ihr noch
einmal abwischen müsst alter das ist
einfach so die erlösung des himmels sie
eigentlich so richtig feste zeiten für
packende freunde von mir zum beispiel
hat immer nur morgens die braucht
einfach morgens um vernünftig den tag zu
starten
ich kann zu jeder zeit morgens oder
abends mehr ist allem ist auch völlig
egal ob ich vor oder nach dem duschen
packen da gibt es ja auch so eine
spaltung in der gesellschaft
hey das wenn ihr so am packen sein und
ihr seid so richtig lang anpacken und
eure füße kribbeln den mann weil ihr
euch die ganze zeit auf eure kinder auf
stützt ich habe heute einfach von dir
geträumt hat diese albträume in der
jugend werde nicht immer schlimmer das
ist offiziell er braucht eine freundin
also so verzweifelt bin ich jetzt nicht
imagine die s14 und es ist ihr freund
das kann nicht sein dass
das kann das kann doch nicht sein oder
oder warum machst du dir eigentlich
nicht einfach selber zu hause einen
tenor das gleiche kanzler leute fragen
die gerne im restaurant geben so
manchmal einfach keinen bock auf selber
kochen sondern will halt okay die hat
relativ wenig mit kochen zu tun ich sehe
den punkt hahaha ich wohne in der
sielstraße ehrenmann einfach vor meiner
haustür vorbei gefahren
du wohnst in dieser straße die zwölf
stunden am tag nur in die richtung geht
und zwölf stunden am tag dann wieder in
die andere richtung
egal wohin willst musste ich erst gar
nichts zu drop christkind heroin das ist
natürlich dass ich anscheinend englische
zuschauer hatte
allerdings ist resort das einzige was
ich da drüben muss hinten in meinem
arschloch also wir machen direkt weiter
in deutschland herrscht in deutschland
herrscht in deutschland herrscht in
deutschland herrscht in deutschland
herrscht seit drei monaten harter
lockdown niemand luca wundert sich dass
alle leben geschlossen haben allein für
diese ersten drei wörter weil ich das
überhaupt nicht
in hamburg genau sagt neuer wall gibt es
einen geilen teeladen kam bei super geil
ich bin dort stammkunde das ist ein
bubble tea laden ich kenne den penaltys
also nichts gegen hat unter euch die
bubble tea mögen und auch nichts gegen
bald hier haben sich aber ja doch schon
ich bin ein mädchen etwa 1 70 groß blond
braune haare haben einen großen bruder
aber war noch nie in hamburg würdest du
trotzdem denken ja ich sie können wir
machen es jetzt ich gerade so wär s
laserdrucker und warum wird er als
abonniert angezeigt alte hat seinen
namen erneut geändert
die saison großes thema ist halt alles
folgt kommentar in meinem namen soll ich
darüber in dem anderen video mal ein
bisschen genauer quatschen oder niemand
wirklich niemand luca ich war auf dem
fahrrad auch luca da bin ich
vorbeigelaufen war auf einem fahrrad
unterwegs und ich bin mir vorbeigelaufen
niemand luca warum sprichst du dein haus
pink haus violett gestrichen ich weiß
nicht wo hier da violett oder wo jeder
lila sieht oder so aber meinen augen ist
das kind das ist ein pinkes haus luca
ich drehe euch mal die kamera um dann
seht ihr auch mal was schönes die kamera
fällt nach gefühl zwei sekunden runter
man hat absolut nichts gesehen einfach
sie auf lobbying andere youtuber ich
suche einen kater luca hey ich bin
verzweifelt single bitte wenn ihr ein
mädchen mit ihrem bruder sehr
ansprechenden zeit leider schon
irgendwie war mir fällt auch nicht rein
ich bin jetzt können wir da wirklich in
den fond allerdings will ich an der
stelle mein heutiges video zu beenden
meine lieben freunde wenn euch luca
reagiert aufkommen wenn euch das video
hier gefallen hat das kann einen daumen
hoch und ein video hier da ich glaube
das brauche ich gar nicht sagen weil das
macht eh kein schwein wer ihr seid ja
keine schweine ihr seid in meinen augen
hier wunderschönen schmetterling also
kann man eigentlich schon mal
[Musik]